Welcome to our program I like to know uh
some TV program. This is a question and
answer space that we have where we have
the opportunity to go over your
questions dig deeper into the Bible and
try to find answers to these questions.
I am in the company of a dear friend,
uh, pastor, mentor, Pastor Stephen
Boore. What a privilege it is to be in
your studio here recording with you.
>> It's a real joy to have you here, Pastor
Miranda. And um, we hope that our
relationship will continue till Jesus
comes.
>> Amen.
>> Or till death do a part.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. Thank you. It is
a privilege to be here as well. and I am
Daniel Miranda, pastor here at the
Central California Conference. Uh we
have some amazing questions as always.
>> Um before we pray, I want to remind you
that you can always send your questions
to the office here uh at the following
email address, tvsv.org.
Again, this is tvs.org.
I'm going to open the program with a
word of prayer. Let's pray. Gracious
heavenly father, which are in heaven, we
are so thankful for the opportunity of
digging deeper into the into your word.
And now, Lord, as we as we try to answer
these questions, we pray that
[clears throat] you may help us stick
only to what the Bible says. We know we
want truth but and nothing but the
truth. So, please Lord uh give us the
wisdom, the understanding, and the skill
to answer these questions from the
biblical perspective. We pray all this
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> All right. We have a question here that
it says it's anonymous. We were not
given the name of the person who sent
this question.
And it was a rather complicated
question.
>> We will do our best to answer it. It
says, "Can you explain 1 Corinthians
7:14? looking at it from the perspective
that children were born with a sinful
nature. So I think it will be helpful if
we read the text if you have it pass
board please.
>> 1 Corinthians chapter 7
>> 14
>> in verse 14
uh this reminds me of what Peter said
about Paul. He wrote some things
difficult to be understood.
>> Yes. [laughter]
>> Uh it says there um for the uh let me
read verse 13 also. And a woman who has
a husband who does not believe, if he is
willing to live with her, let her not
divorce him. For the unbelieving husband
is sanctified by the wife, and the
unbelieving wife is sanctified by the
husband.
Otherwise, your children would be
unclean, but now they are holy.
what is this talking about here? So it
would be good to to look at the context
here. Paul is not talking about being
unequally yolked. So that that that is
the first thing we want to say. He's
talking about a couple that were
non-Christians where they got together
>> but one of the spouses now has
converted. Right?
>> That is the context. So in that context,
Paul is saying that you don't
necessarily have to divorce your spouse.
>> There's actually benefits if you
continue with
>> with your spouse. And verse 14 tells us
that the unbelieving husband is
sanctified by the wife. So it's very
interesting that from Paul's perspective
here is not the other way around. It's
not that the believing
spouse will be unsanctified or defiled
by the unbelieving spouse. But to the
contrary, for the unbelieving husband is
sanctified by the wife, that is the
believing wife and the unbelieving wife
is sanctified by the believing husband.
Otherwise,
your children would be uncleaned,
but now they are holy. What I
understand, pastor board, from this text
that the the question is based on this
expression, your children would be
unclean. I don't believe that this is
talking about sinful nature, the nature
of of humanity in in a sense.
>> This is just talking about the the
sanctification of the home as we see it
here. What Paul is arguing, what I
understand from this context is that the
there is a blessing and advantage when
in the home there is one that believes
and and as long as there is a faithful
person in the home, the home will be
sanctified by the presence of that
believing faithful person
>> because of the holy influence.
>> Because of the holy
>> of a believer.
>> Exactly.
>> And the holy influence also spills over
to the children.
>> That's right. That's what I see in this
text in that sense. they will be you
know they will be unclean. Uh the the
the rupture of this marriage
relationship will affect the children
and and and
you know not only will bring pain and
sorrow but but the holy influence that
the believing father or mother can exert
on the children will also be affected.
So I believe from from this perspective
and this context this is what Paul is
referring to. I think that um you know
the ideal would be if that both
>> both
>> are believers.
>> Correct.
>> And therefore that would be a very
positive influence on the child or the
children. Mhm.
>> But if you have the unusual case where
one of them comes to believe and the
other one doesn't, but they're willing
to continue living together,
>> the influence of the believing husband
or the influence of the believing wife
will spill over on the the children will
have a sanctifying influence on the
children and also husband and wife and
wife and husband.
>> And I have seen this in my ministry. I'm
sure you've seen it where where there is
uh either the mother and the father
>> uh that they they continue the
relationship
>> and eventually the believing spouse won
the unbelieving spouse and the children
also accepted Jesus Christ. So for the
influence of those just one person the
whole family was sanctified.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and I've seen cases like that.
>> Sure. And I've seen cases where where
the husband has been um uh enimical to
the religion and practices of the wife.
>> But the wife because of her sweetness,
because of her patience and because of
her love uh in the long run after a long
period of time, the husband has become a
believer.
>> Yes.
>> And so uh you know I think that's what
the apostle Paul is referring to in this
verse.
>> Yes. I think so.
Well, thank you. We can move on to the
next question. Again, this is anonymous.
My question is about the seven trumpets.
Uh my understanding is that the trumpets
are pronouncing judgments on certain
specific areas. And then it summarizes
>> [snorts]
>> uh some of these trumpets. Uh and then
it asked about the
third, fourth, fifth and sixth trumpets
when there's a description
uh of the papacy, wormwood, the lie
being dimmed, the French revolution, the
gathering of the righteous and the
wicked to both sides. I appreciate your
answer because this this is such a dense
question. We briefly touched on the
trumpets in a previous program. I think
uh pastor Bo we can refer them to to
your guides your and your series.
>> Yeah, this is a very complex question uh
because uh it would take us uh several
programs to answer the question. Uh but
the good news is that u in one of our
anchor schools of theology
uh I did a series on the seven trumpets
and uh the study notes are available. uh
it's a rather bulky study notes. It has
um well going on 400 pages of material
and so I would recommend that u that the
person who asked this question uh which
his name is anonymous [laughter]
because we don't have his name. Uh check
out our website uh download our app and
you can download these study notes for
free.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
Let's move on to the next question. This
is from the island of Jamaica. Beautiful
place. Uh the person writing is Prince.
Hello SMTV team. The ten commandments
are 10 principles and 10 promises. And
these are eternal laws that from the
foundation of God's government sins of
eternity. That being true, I'd like to
know how is the principle of the seventh
commandment not engaging in adultery
applicable to angels or other extra
planetary non-human intelligences since
they would not have need to engage in
marital affairs like humanity was given
for populating earth and repopulating
heaven. Also a related question that
they are not moral beings so would not
need were not given nor endowed with the
ability to interpret the moral law. Why
is the animal kingdom given the
privilege of procreation since they are
not for repopulating heaven? I figure
one reason may be to populate earth
because men would need their help for
various reasons. survival, food, manual
labor, duties to the earth itself, etc.
during this period of sin while things
continue to die. So God designed them to
replenish during the period of sin until
the earth is made new. So two questions
in one one is about the applicability of
the principle the seven commandment to
heavenly beings uh not engaging in
adultery and the purpose of procreation
for animals.
>> Well we uh I think this person uh
actually answers prince actually answers
partially the question that he's asking.
>> Yes.
>> Uh at the very beginning he says the ten
commandments are 10 principles.
Uh okay. So um we need to look at the
principles and not the specific uh case
the specific wording.
>> Um the book of revelation might provide
a clue.
>> U it speaks about a harlot
who commits fornication
with the kings of the earth.
Now a woman in scripture represents the
church.
Pure woman, a pure church who is
faithful to her husband Jesus Christ.
A vile woman or a harlot woman represent
a fallen church that abandons the lovely
relationship with Christ and depends on
the power of the kings of the earth or
the state.
>> Uh is the union of church and state
fornication in principle? It is. Is it a
violation of the commandment that says
that you're not supposed to fornicate?
Of course.
>> Who was the great fornicator according
to that definition that the Bible
provides?
>> Satan.
>> Satan because he forsook
Jesus and he fell in love with himself.
>> Has to do with loyalty to God.
>> Yes.
>> So, so that is fornication
spiritually or symbolically speaking. Uh
you don't in other words you don't have
to go to bed with another man's wife to
commit adultery. You can also commit
adultery spiritually speaking by joining
with the world.
>> Right?
>> Don't unite unequally with unbelievers.
>> Yes.
>> The apostle Paul says in 1 Corinthians
or 2 Corinthians chapter 6. So uh this
has the the commandment on not
committing adultery or fornication
uh has an extended meaning
>> which applies to spiritual fornication
as well and also as theft. Did Lucifer
want to steal a position that was not
his?
>> Yes he did.
>> Of course. Did he covet?
>> Yes. Did he want to be God? Of course.
He broke all of the ten commandments in
principle.
>> Yeah. And so in that sense, the
commandments are eternal in principle,
but they're adapted to humanity because,
you know, like the fourth commandment
speaks about the man's servant and the
maid servant. Well, it's it's expressed
in an adapted way to the sinful
condition that we're living in, right?
But the principle is eternal and applies
to the entire universe.
>> Yes, absolutely. [clears throat] And I
think that Wells answers this part,
first part of the question. um the the
the ten commandments as they're given
they're adapted and then why says this
to humanity
>> right
>> but we need to look up the principles as
you well explained pastor bore now the
second part of the question was talking
about the procreation of animals uh what
is the difference why god gave animals
also the right to procreate
>> I think uh he answers his own question
>> u animals are vitally important
important to the ecosystem.
>> Yes.
>> Of this world.
>> Without animals,
uh it it would be uh the ecosystem would
simply not work.
>> Uh so God created animals and uh he
foresaw that there was going to be sin
and because of sin there was going to be
death and therefore it was necessary for
animals to pro to uh procreate uh in
order to keep the ecosystem functioning
properly.
>> Amen. Let's take for example a vulture.
I mean is a vulture uh very necessary
for the ecosystem? Of course it is.
Yeah.
>> Uh and so you look at all of the
different animals uh in the world, they
all have a function uh within uh the
functioning of nature.
>> Yes. And in Genesis
chapter 1 verse 28
[clears throat]
uh after it describes the creation of
man and and the man and the woman. It
says then God blessed them and God said
to them be fruitful and multiply fill
the earth and subdue it. Have dominion
over the fish of the sea, over the birds
plural of the earth and over every
living thing that moves on the earth.
When it says have dominion, God is not
the dominion that we think of today
where we can just mistreat them and kill
them and things like that. No, he he
were they were to take care of nature.
>> Animals were
>> uh humans companions in this work of
creation. One would not have been enough
as the human race was going to multiply.
So the amnimals needed to multiply to
serve the various purposes in nature and
to humanity as well.
>> Right. Right.
Okay. Well, thank you. Great question.
Thank you, Prince. Now, we go to another
question. Again, this is anonymous. Um,
greetings, family. The spirit of
prophecy says that there will be a time
when the saints will hear the day and
hour of the second coming of Christ
after probation closes. Yes, that's
true. I would like for you to explain it
from the Bible only.
Well, uh, you know, basically there's no
place that I find in scripture that says
that God is going to announce the day
and the hour of, uh, of his coming.
>> Um, but, uh, the spirit of prophecy does
make it clear that, and by the way, this
is not before the close of probation.
This is after the close of probation.
>> In fact, after the the question says,
>> yes, it's after the close of probation.
And not only that, but when you look at
the context of Ellen White's statement,
this is at the very end of the time of
trouble.
>> Yes.
>> Where where uh all cases are already
decided.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh so it's not like uh you know he's
giving a prophecy before the close of
probation so that people start fixing
that Jesus is coming in such and such a
date. at this point uh only the
righteous will understand
>> the day and the hour of the coming of
Christ.
>> That that is correct. It's true. Um
we don't we don't have a specific text
that says that. But when we read
the other elements that Ellen White
describes, this is the chapter on the
time of trouble
>> in the great controversy.
We see that she's using biblical
language in the context when this voice
is heard from heaven. So let let me take
you to Revelation chapter 16
and verse 17 and 18. This is the context
of the seventh bow bowl or the seventh
last plague. It says then the seventh
angel poured out his ball into the
earth. This is just the last one. And a
loud voice came out of the temple of
heaven from the throne, saying, "It is
dawn."
And there were noises and thunderings
and lightnings, and there was a great
earthquake, such as a mighty and great
earthquake, as had not occurred since
men were on the earth. You know, every
time the Bible describes a scene with
thundering, lightnings, earthquake,
noises is because God is going to say
something important, very important. We
see this at Sinai when God pronounced
the ten commandments
>> you know and we see it throughout
throughout history in specific moments
uh you know the death of Jesus. So so
the Bible only says that he says it is
done but Ellen White even describes
additional elements and this is in the
context of all these thunderings and you
know a voice from God is heard from
heaven um announcing the day and the
hour of his coming. So, uh, again, Len Y
is is is is taking us and showing
details that the Bible doesn't give us,
but they do not contradict with with
with the biblical revelation. At least
when the Bible says that we do not know
the day or the hour, you know, is not
given to us now. But here in the context
of the time of trouble, there will be a
time when it says it is done. So for
sure even if we didn't we didn't have
the day or the hour those who are alive
and hear this voice they know it's it
that's it.
>> Uh that's it. Now Jesus is coming.
>> Yeah.
>> So
>> and and at that point when uh if you
look at the book great controversy uh
the chapter God's people delivered where
she mentions that he announces the day
and the hour. It's in the context of
when he says it is done.
>> Exactly. At that moment, she says that
the living righteous are glorified.
>> And there's a special resurrection.
>> Yes.
>> Which those who pierced him, the Bible
teaches that.
>> And also uh those who died in the faith
of the third angel's message, which
Revelation 14:13
indicates, blessed are those who die
>> from now on in the Lord. Uh and then um
Jesus
begins his second coming and he comes
down and when he's above the earth at
the conclusion of the second coming then
he calls forth the dead who died before
1844.
>> And uh that is found in Daniel 12:es 1
and two.
>> That's right.
>> I mean so so it's found in the Bible. So
what Ellen White is saying there is not
really something uh revolutionary that's
being added to the text uh and that
doesn't fit it fits perfectly with all
of the events that are taking place at
that time.
>> Absolutely. Thank you, Pastor Bo. Uh we
have one more question. This is actually
coming from someone that has your name,
Stephen.
>> Good name. Good name.
>> Yes. I have hard I have a hard time
focusing without my hands doing
something. Is it wrong to crochet on
Sabbath while listening to the Bibles or
sermons to keep my hands busy? It is not
for stuff to sell. I have family who is
split on this. I don't see it as a work,
but others do. Could you shed some light
on this for me? Thanks and God bless.
>> Uh don't pay attention to what others
say. Listen to your conscience. Mhm.
>> I do not like making lists
of things that you can do and you can't
do on Sabbath.
>> The Bible gives us a principle. Don't
buy or sell,
>> you know,
>> don't engage in secular work,
>> right? Don't invol be involved in
secular work. It gives you the
principles and then God is giving you a
conscience which if sanctified is going
to lead you to the right decision. Now
uh the key here is it's not for stuff to
sell.
>> Uh if the person is crocheting for uh
say sweaters for the homeless or people
who are in need, it would be different
than uh than crocheting uh a sweater say
to to sell to make financial gain. M
>> um I would be the last to tell her
you're sinning because you're doing
this,
>> right?
>> God has given you a conscience,
>> Be sincere.
Say, "Lord, show me." And don't
necessarily pay attention to those who
say yay or nay, right?
>> Because we need to be careful about
other people being our conscience.
>> Yes. Yeah. I don't see a moral issue
here either. Perhaps I I would encourage
my dear brother Stephen if if you
haven't done it. I see that the main the
main issue here is your your difficult
difficulty with focusing without your
hands uh doing something. Um there is a
student that I am the chaplain of our
one of our schools uh the Nova Junior
Academy and there is a student there.
He's he's wonderful. He's one of the
best students. I would say the best
student. He has the best grades.
But you know when I am given the chapel
or or saying something he always needs
to be cutting paper. He just and he cuts
paper and makes little figures. And at
first I thought he wasn't listening to
me but he was he was very attentive but
he just he just needs to cut paper and
and just you know do the animals that he
likes to do and things like that. But
that is a way in which he can stay
focused. uh is a is a condition that he
has uh that perhaps could be treated,
could not be treated. I'm not an expert
in in these things. Uh perhaps it's an
attention deficit disorder. Whatever I I
I I see here will be that would be the
issue, but it's not a moral issue. It's
not a moral issue, right?
>> So, if you can focus, if you can if you
can understand your sermon, listening to
Bible sermons better, doing that, hey,
that's good for you. You found something
that works for you and that's fine. And
if you're and if you're making something
that's going to be a blessing to other
people,
>> you know, you're not working for
yourself
>> for your own uh benefit, but you're
actually doing something that is going
to benefit other people. Uh I don't see
a moral issue involved either,
>> right? Yes, we agree. Well, thank you.
Thank you, Stephen. And and uh I would
say as Pastor Bore mentioned, just just
listen to your conscience.
uh just between you and God. If your if
your conscience does not condemn you,
you're fine. Uh you are I can see you
understand the sanctity of the Sabbath
and and may God bless you. Well, we have
come to the end of our program and um we
we want to thank you for tuning in. We
want to thank you for sending your
questions. Uh we hope to see you again.
God bless you and take care.